good all right
[Music]
okay
all right
is
really works four
like this
i was going to say what's up hanson
without
further ado
okay
robbie
hey robbie can you flash a thumbs up if
you can hear us
yeah it's
hot mike
okay so chris can robbie give me you
know
[Music]
oh
one
two
three
four five six
seven eight
nine 10.
all good
audio good
[Music]
yeah that's totally fine
yes when they speak
turn the page
something will go wrong
is
oh
okay
[Music]
i'm sorry
it works
so what's your name
a long times
is
[Music]
all right
bluetooth
ready to connect via bluetooth
[Music]
all right
is
[Music]
oh
always
is
okay
issues
a minute
appreciation
oh
yes
is
no
foreign
okay
okay
foreign
[Music]
oh really
is
you know what it is
hello
mic check one two this is a microphone
check for the media room and if any
other media who wants to check their
mics
what's up bill
[Music]
check one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
ten nine eight seven six five four three
one
we just got a two minute warning fellas
[Music]
hmm
one two three
all right how about now that would help
right
one two three
on the left
left side left side right side we good
awesome
thank you
i'm sorry
[Music]
so red's on red zone off is off right
okay
you're good
okay
thank you
[Music]
okay
just opened up
social media
[Music]
good afternoon i'm john miller deputy
commissioner for intelligence and
counterterrorism of the new york city
police department
with me police commissioner kishan
sewell
chief of detectives james essig
uh brianne peace the united states
attorney for the eastern district of new
york
mike driscoll the assistant director in
charge of the fbi's new york office
john devito special agent in charge atf
these are the partners who have been
working with us from the first moment
of this incident and we have important
information to transmit today
first i would like to go to the mayor
live from gracie mansion
[Music]
[Music]
my fellow new yorkers
we got him
we got him
i cannot
thank the men and women
the new york city police department
enough
as well as
our federal agents
our state police
our first responders from the 9 11
operators
to
the various men and women from our
medical professions
we got him
and said to new yorkers
we want to protect the people of this
city
and apprehend those
who believe they can bring terror to
everyday new yorkers
and i want to thank every day from the
office who called their tips who
responded
who helped those passengers who were
injured
33 shots
but less than 30 hours later
we're able to say
we got him
thank you commissioner for your
leadership the job well done
and now police commissioner of the city
of new york keisha sewell
good afternoon everyone and thank you
for being here
i am truly fortunate to stand here among
these extraordinary investigators and
federal partners to make this
announcement
moments ago frank robert james was
stopped on the street and arrested by
members of the new york city police
department
officers in response to a crime stoppers
tip stopped mr james at 1 42 p.m at the
corner of saint mark's place and first
avenue in manhattan
he was taken into custody without
incident and has been transported to an
nypd facility
he will be charged with committing
yesterday's appalling crime in brooklyn
i want to commend all the investigators
and analysts who took part in this all
hands on deck investigation
literally hundreds of nypd detectives
worked doggedly during the last 30 hours
to bring this together
they did so in tandem with a vast number
of our law enforcement partners
including those from the fbi nypd joint
terrorism task force the atf nypd crime
gun intelligence center
and the regional task force led by the
united states marshal service
we hope this arrests bring some solace
to the victims and the people of the
city of new york
we used every resource at our disposal
to gather and process significant
evidence that directly links mr james to
the shooting
we were able to shrink his world quickly
there was nowhere left for him to run
i'd like to turn it over to chief james
essex for details of the investigation
good afternoon everybody
i'd like to update the public on
yesterday's incident on the subway in
brooklyn on the manhattan-bound n train
through the course of this investigation
we developed additional information and
evidence
mr frank james our person of interest
now became a wanted individual for
yesterday's horrific incident
mr james is a male 62 years old he is
known to us and has ties in wisconsin
ohio
pennsylvania new jersey and new york
city
his arrest history in new york is nine
prior arrests dating from 1992
to 1998
those include possession of burglary
tools four times criminal sex act
theft of service two times he was
arrested on a new jersey warrant he also
has a criminal tampering
he has three arrests in new jersey
1991
1992 and 2007
there for trespass larceny and
disorderly conduct
so yesterday
we recovered video of him
prior to the incident entering the kings
highway subway station
he has the same black cart
that he is later recovered on the crime
scene
the pictures are to my right over here
this statement is available
electronically
this station is three blocks from where
he recovered the u-haul truck that he
rented in philadelphia the key to that
truck was recovered at the crime scene
this jacket the distinctive orange
jacket was also recovered
as well as his construction helmet he
was wearing
and we we recovered that in a garbage
bin in transit
we believe but this is still early in
the investigation that after firing his
weapon 33 times at innocent new york
city subway riders mr james ordered an r
train that had pulled into the station
went one stop up and exited at 25th
street station
we also have a picture of that
the gun used in this a nine millimeter
glock which was recovered at this crime
scene
was bought was purse chips by mr james
in 2011 in ohio
we tracked mr james and his last known
whereabouts was 7th avenue and 9th
street in park slope
entering the subway
minutes ago
thankfully
nypd patrol officers from the ninth
precinct
responded to saint mark's and first
avenue where they apprehended him
without incident
this case was quickly solved using
technology video canvassing and then
getting that information out to the
public
so i can't speak highly enough of the
partners we had the fbi mike driscoll
atf john devito us
district attorney from easton uh brianne
peace
uh and and the coordination and
within
the detective bureau tommy golotti from
intel our transit bureau our patrol
services bureau a phenomenal job less
than 30
hours later to arrest this individual so
with that i like to turn it over to
brienne peace
good afternoon thank you
yesterday was a dark day for all of us
but the bright spots of the incredible
heroism of our fellow new yorkers
helping each other in the time of crisis
the quick response by our first
responders and the hard work by all of
our law enforcement partners that has
been ongoing
is truly
a bright spot here
today
frank james has been charged by
complaint in brooklyn federal court with
one count of violating 18 usc sections
1992 a7 and b1
which prohibits terrorists and other
violent attacks
against mass transportation systems
he has been apprehended he will be
arraigned in federal court in brooklyn
and if convicted he will face a sentence
of up to life
imprisonment my office is prepared to
prove beyond a reasonable doubt that on
april 12 2022 in sunset park brooklyn in
the eastern district of new york frank
james did knowingly and without lawful
authority and permission commit an act
including the use of a dangerous weapon
with the intent to cause death and
serious bodily injury to passengers and
mta employees on the new york city
subway system
the government will prove among other
things that james traveled across state
lines
in order to commit the offense
and transported materials across a state
line in aid of the commission of the
offense
we in the eastern district of new york
u.s attorney's office are working
closely with all of our law enforcement
partners the fbi nypd atf u.s marshals
service and others
including the kings county district
attorney's office
and my office and our law enforcement
partners will use every tool at our
disposal
to bring this individual justice and
bring justice to new yorkers and restore
safety and peace of mind to all and will
continue to do so as this case proceeds
good afternoon and thank you all for
being here today
as mr peace just discussed mr james is
now facing a federal charge for his
actions
a terrorist attack on mass transit
we have two ways that you can get in
contact with us because i want to be
very clear that this is still an ongoing
investigation
if you have additional information
regarding mr jane's activity or if you
have digital information please reach
out to us
contact the fbi 1-800 call fbi
or you can provide digital media through
fbi.gov
brooklyn shooting
we need to hear from you so we can fully
understand all the events that have
occurred over the last 30 hours
it's crucial that we receive the
assistance of the public as we piece
this case together
there has been some reports
that fbi holdings to date
had a tie to mr james i want to be very
clear
that
to date we have found no record of an
investigation of frank r james by an fbi
office before the shooting yesterday
reports that fbi's new mexico field
office previously investigated him are
inaccurate
i want to thank our partners in this
case
the nypd
the atf us marshals and the u.s
attorney's office and all the members of
the
fbi nypd joint terrorism task force
we've had such a tremendous response
from all of our partners in this case
that have led us to this moment now
i also want to take a quick moment to
highlight
the work of the jttf i'm fortunate i get
to work with them every day it's truly
an outstanding group of people led by
sac carrie farley who's who spearheaded
this investigation they've done an
outstanding job on this as they have
every time new york has faced
a threat of this nature
so thank you and i'd like to turn it
over to john devito from the epa
good afternoon everyone again my name is
john devito i'm specialized in charge
for atf here in new york state
one of the key
points that uh
hey dick driscoll pointed out was that
we could not have done this without the
public's health
first let me say our thoughts and
prayers and actions for the past two
days have been with the victims as well
as all new yorkers
the men and women of atf have been
working side by side with nypd fdny
marshals
fbi
to solve this heinous crime
which we have
immediately after the attack new york
city crime gun intelligence center or
cgic which is a unit comprised of highly
skilled analysts investigators from atf
nypd as well as a myriad of other vital
partners
whose sole purpose is to collect analyze
and disseminate actual intelligence
regarding gun violence
just imagine a team of dedicated
professionals
exploiting every nugget of intel
from gun violence the firearms
and then weaponizing that information to
use it against the people that are
terrorizing our communities
that's your cg
the timeline on this gun's life spans 16
years in five states
and i'm very proud to say that late
yesterday evening about 12 hours after
this attack
atf agents were able to close the loop
on that extensive time span and
determine that frank james purchased
that firearm from a federal firearms
licensee
in ohio in 2011.
so essentially we tied that gun
utilizing the shooting to our target and
now we have our target in custody
thank you
okay uh we're gonna be in that we've
told you almost
everything we have to say able to answer
some very limited questions
there was a person who called crime
stoppers we're reviewing who exactly
made that call
is it clear yet
what the motivation
but i i think first and foremost we were
looking to get this guy off the street
before he did any any more carnage
brought any more carnage to the city
as to the investigation into the motive
and to looking scouring his social media
that's still part of the ongoing
investigation but again first and
foremost we wanted to take him off the
street the investigation is continuing
into the motive into his social media
postings
you said mr james uh walked into a
apartment
station what time was that
that was 9 15 yesterday
so the incident occurs at 8 24.
so he leaves he exited the 25th street
station house shortly after 8 24 the r
train pulls in we catch him next going
into a park slope on 7th avenue and 9th
street at 9 15.
and then we grab him today but we had
literally hundreds of detectives out
scouring video throughout the crime
scene and beyond and so this is 9am
excuse me
yes that was him yesterday at 9 50.
all right mark
do you have any idea where he was
previously today any ideas on his
whereabouts was he kept attracted anyway
did he say when he was arrested
his arrest was just literally minutes
ago uh so
where we haven't even
just arrived at the precinct shortly uh
as to his whereabouts that's part of the
investigation detectives are out going
through uh video canvases
and we're going to backtrack that and
that will take literally weeks okay um a
two-part question the first is the nypd
previous to yesterday's attack had any
um
complaints or did they look into any of
the cameras being out not just at 36th
street but at 45th and 25th and
additionally is there any indication
that um
mr james was going to do any more
attacks in new york city
yeah as far as i'm doing doing any more
attacks that's again that's part of the
investigation our main focus was to take
him off the street immediately
but go ahead do you know how he
purchased the gun if he had the criminal
record
yeah you you can't have a felony
conviction to purchase the gun so he had
no felony convictions okay new york what
um
has the mayor's uh security detail been
returned to his typical size and scope
so we're
yes can you take us from the crime
stopper tip to the arrest what happened
in between
how is he located
the crime stopper tip today
hey julia good afternoon
crime stopper tip comes in
reports that the mail is in the
mcdonald's on sixth street and and first
avenue in the ninth precinct down on the
lower east side east village officers
respond to the mcdonald's he's not in
the mcdonald's they start driving around
the neighborhood looking for him they
see him on the corner of saint markson
first and they take him into custody he
no incident and take him into
cameras and subway custody just to make
sure they're all working in the future
so the the camera systems in the in the
subway system are not nypd cameras
they're owned and maintained by the mta
we have access to them we do regularly
look and see which cameras are working
which ones are not but the
responsibility for those cameras belongs
to the mta uh
not at this time if we do we'll let you
know
um in any interviews that took place
rather than yesterday with any of the
surviving victims as well as
we have witnesses on the train who said
he was sitting in the back corner of the
second car
uh and he popped
uh the smoke grenade
and we have one witness who says
uh what what did you do he goes oops and
then he pops the two brandishes the
firearm and fires 33 times that that we
are in the process and we are asking for
anybody's help who was on that subway
train or on that platform
to reach out
to uh to the uh crime stoppers at
1-800-877 tips with any information
we're still looking for witnesses and
anybody who has information who was on
the scene okay new york times hi can you
tell us anything more about this
guy
i know from what experts say that the
clocks aren't supposed to do that is
our crime scene is still processing that
scene it goes to the lab and they'll
give us a report that's it's still very
early in the investigation for that
[Music]
that requires no nexus to be foreign
that's correct the the statute is
um titled terrorism and other violent
attacks and mass transportation so if
there's a federal interest of course and
protecting mass transportation hubs
and infrastructure and so that's the
jurisdiction but
we we're not going to comment further or
we're still investigating the motive and
things like that so can't come further
all right last question to juliette
yes
who can talk about his contact with
social services or if he had any here in
new york
that's going to be part of the
investigation as well so we're not able
to speak to that at this moment
that's part of our investigation
especially
thank you
[Music]
here's the last last question thank you
i'm wondering if there's uh do we have
any motive in terms of sunset why sun's
that hard or was it random
no idea so uh just to close
we also want to acknowledge um our
partners sometimes jousting partners in
the media
for putting all these pictures out
for spreading um uh this story from the
time we did the press conference
yesterday
that was a critical effect on raising
the kind of public awareness that as the
com as the commissioner said uh was able
to give him very few choices um in terms
of where to go so we appreciate your
efforts as well thank you very much
[Music]
you